mais qui a tué pamela rose deux agents
connaissent la réponse je ne vais rien
vous dire à part ce que je veux dire
c'est à dire je voudrais vous dire je
peux vous dire je peux rien vous dire
mais je peux vous dire que je ne peux
rien vous dire
mais j'aimerais bien vous le dire mais
je peux pas enfin par ozone parlez vous
dire c'est à dire pas je peux rien vous
dire
sauf un je ne peux rien vous dire ils
connaissent le coupable mais personne ne
veut le croire
injecter - le scéren de la vérité si je
mens épuré je vous dis que j'ai vu je
les ai vus sur ma vie de ma mère
solvimo maire sorti le saint bonnet le
ce en quoi parce qu'elle m'a pas dit ça
qui vous l'a pas dit a sachez preuve